i
a
[Música]
ah
bélgica se ha convertido en los últimos
dos meses uno de los países con mayor
incidencia de coronavirus de toda europa
han aumentado los casos también los
pacientes más graves en cuidados
intensivos y también las muertes y
aunque ahora mismo los casos siguen
siendo muy altos está empezando a ver
una ralentización los epidemiólogos
consideran que las medidas restrictivas
en todo el país como el 'toque de queda'
o el cierre de la hostelería están
teniendo un impacto positivo en esta
ralentización pero las autoridades del
país creen que no hay que bajar la
guardia y hay que aprender de los
errores del pasado por ello en un futuro
del confinamiento va a ser muchísimo más
lento para evitar un rápido aumento de
casos de nuevo bélgica ha sufrido con
muchísima más intensidad esta segunda
ola debido en parte a que tras las
vacaciones de verano hizo muy mal tiempo
y mucha gente se centró en espacios
cerrados lo que propagó con muchísima
más facilidad el virus por ello las
autoridades advierten no hay que bajar
la guardia
piden cautela sobre todo también para
las fiestas de navidad que ya están a la
vuelta de la esquina
[Música]
es la preocupación en italia ante el
aumento exponencial del contagio en los
últimos días expertos de la comunidad
científica estiman que la situación está
fuera de control esta semana el país
registró el peor dato de número de
muertos en 24 horas desde el pasado 14
de abril en un mes el número de
pacientes hospitalizados en las unidades
de cuidados intensivos se multiplicó por
7 una situación que tiene a los
hospitales al borde del colapso en
varias regiones principalmente en
lombardía la región que cuenta con el
mayor número de casos pero también en el
sur del país son las que cuentan con
infraestructuras sanitarias menos
desarrolladas la federación italiana de
médicos y anestesistas ha lanzado un
grito de alarma pidiendo más
restricciones e incluso un nuevo
confinamiento general algo que el
gobierno italiano ha querido evitar a
toda costa temiendo un descalabro de la
economía italiana
[Música]
españa ha sido uno de los primeros
países europeos en ser golpeado por la
segunda ola de la pandemia una situación
que ha vuelto a poner al límite al
personal sanitario que continúa
denunciando sus precarias condiciones
laborales por otro lado cada comunidad
autónoma aplica medidas distintas para
frenar los nuevos contagios mientras que
por ejemplo en el norte del país
asturias tiene cerrada toda actividad no
esencial aquí en madrid todo continúa
abierto eso sí el objetivo del gobierno
español es evitar un nuevo confinamiento
domiciliario como el que ya vivimos en
la primera ola de la pandemia y es que
en los últimos días la tendencia de los
nuevos contagios se mantiene estable a
pesar de que ayer se batió un nuevo
récord de esta segunda ola en términos
de fallecimientos en 24 horas más de 400
personas perdieron la vida por lakovic
19 por eso la mirada del país está
puesta en una potencialmente cercana
campaña de vacunación que según ha
anunciado el ministro de sanidad podría
empezaría el próximo mes de enero tras
conocerse el anuncio del avanzado estado
de la vacuna estadounidense the fighter
[Música]